an American hero is on that train her
name Kate Warne she was the first woman
detective in the US and on that very
train she saved
Abraham Lincoln's life
[Music]
when Kay Warren applied for a position
in the Pinkerton Detective Agency the
detectives tried to turn her away they
didn't think a woman could do the job
Kate argued that women can be very good
at uncovering secrets she won the men
over and became America's first female
detective she proved to be a gifted
investigator working many cases and
going undercover in the years leading up
to the civil war in disguise as a rich
Southern socialite Kate uncovered a plot
to assassinate newly elected Abraham
Lincoln the killers plan to intercept
him along the train route on his way to
take office Kate and her agency worked
with the president-elect to carry out a
daring plan after a dinner in
Philadelphia
Lincoln throw on a disguise and snuck to
the train depot in secret he met up with
Kate who posed as his sister
she had bribed a conductor to reserve
the back of the train car to hide her
and the undercover president-elect the
plan was a success Cade stood guard over
Lincoln while he slept
neither his assassins or the other
passengers know he was on the train
legend has it her watchful eye during
that sleepless night is the inspiration
for the term Private Eye American
history could have forever been changed
if not for the first female detective
Kate Warne
you
[Music]